we continue our education in America
series this morning with one man who is
turning the learning process upside down
his series of really simple videos is
being called revolutionary as CBS News
correspondent John Blackstone reports it
would be music to the ears of any
educator what ten-year-old Megan CERN
has to say about her favorite teacher he
makes math really easy in a really kind
of conversation away we'd be on the
number line he is Salman Khan negative
seven dollars it's like saying that I 07
dollars Khan is the voice and the brains
behind the Khan Academy the free
educational website that some believe is
leading a revolution in teaching there's
no nonsense there's no D focusing on the
material it really is what it is Khan's
lessons are unscripted and unadorned
let's divide both sides of this equation
by his voice over a black screen as he
writes or doodles his style has changed
little since this all began back in 2004
as YouTube videos to help his young
cousins nine times the six he's now
recorded more than 2,400 lessons on
everything from simple arithmetic to
college level biology anyone can watch
for free people are more likely to say
thank you when it's free and you know
thank you thank thank you is worth a lot
but what are cons lessons worth the Los
Altos School District is trying to
figure that out what else could we do
besides last year the distributions in
five classes the students did well
enough that this year the con method is
in 40 classes to be used by every fifth
and sixth grader in the district we
found that our students are really
engaged in this type of learning that it
was a great addition to what we are
already doing you might say this
California School has flipped students
get their lectures at home and come to
school to do their homework
fundamentally changing the role of the
teacher the kids can really move through
at their own pace and then I can see
who's struggling at home students listen
to Khan's online lessons in the
classroom they practice what they
learned well teacher Courtney cadwell
works with those who need help when
they're having fun and they're wanting
to do math that tells me that this is a
good thing this educational overhaul
comes from a man who was working as a
hedge fund analyst until 2009 Khan has a
Harvard MBA and three degrees from MIT
okay you're kind of a math geek I guess
are you yes and in the best form of the
word in the beginning he financed the
Khan Academy from his own savings until
he was discovered by some people with
money well it's amazing I I think you've
just got a glimpse of the future of
Education thank you the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and Google are among
the big donors that have allowed the
Khan Academy to add nearly a dozen
software engineers it's really smartly
done on the computer and I love being on
the computer with more than two million
users a month many others seem to love
Khan's lessons too I've already talked
to 70 million lessons and he will be
happy to teach millions more smallest to
the largest jump lacks tone CBS News
Mountain View California